put a bunch of teenagers on a tv set and
what do you get
a whole lot of footage for a blooper
reel the cast of stranger things had
loads of fun fails and jokes on set
let's have a look to see the best behind
the scenes moments from the series
the premiere episode of the series
included a kiss between actors joe kiri
and natalia dyer
on-screen smooches can be awkward but
the young actors didn't hesitate when it
came to fooling around and making a joke
of the scene
we knew they were talented actors and
now we can add
sock puppetry to the list no i'm kidding
why do you think i want it nice and
quiet
the famous snowball scene near the end
of season 2
definitely had the young actors nervous
as for a lot of them
they were going to experience their
first kiss
over and over and over again
let's be honest kissing can be awkward
as it is
add a camera crew parents and being a
teenage actor
awkward through the roof to add to the
occasion
mike whispered i'm coming in to 11
before the kiss
he was like okay i'm coming
we in even see the subtle movement of
his lips in this scene
we sure hope someone told finn that
that's not the best choice if he wants
to keep getting smooches
sadie sink and millie bobby brown seem
to have endless energy
considering they perform full-blown
musical numbers between
takes it's getting always singing all
the time it's getting
milly and sadie the sweet friendship
between the two comes across in this
video and it's just
the best maybe the reason bobby brown
had a double take correcting herself
saying
anna is because she was filled with
excitement to entertain her bff
[ __ ] please go back home not only is
this super fun
but it shows off just how talented these
young actors are
oh we're not done with the singing we're
just getting started
remember this creepy scene in the third
ep of season three
turns out behind the scenes it was quite
the elaborate production
my name's ketchup and my name is
yet again these ladies show off their
killer musical and comedic skills it's
definitely a good way to make these
spooky scenes easier to film
is there a million sadie cd coming out
soon
we're pretty sure we'll be buying it
talented
and thoughtful here is another reason we
love millie bobby brown
while no animals were harmed in the
making of season three
a dummy did suffer some minor injuries
fortunately bobby brown is a thoughtful
scene partner
hopefully that dummy didn't have too
many takes left
sorry while a lot of the lion flubs come
from the young actors on set
the adults have their fair share of
mistakes we can only
imagine how wild that set is so it must
be tricky to stay concentrated
who knew grandma could be so funny
with so many takes we're not even sure
who to blame for the endless laughter
it's your grandma it's your grandma
[Music]
no it's your grandma obviously there are
pros though
since they finally nailed that scene
it's your grandma after a whole lot of
bloopers that is
naturally actors will sometimes mess up
their lines a bit
but sometimes the flubs are so big they
change the whole
meaning last time we checked dungeons
and dragons
isn't exactly known for being full of
girls
but stranger things have happened today
is a new day
a day full of girls
today is a new day a day free of girls
maybe it was a freudian slip nice try
will
speaking of dungeons and dragons the
jargon can definitely be pretty tricky
so it's no surprise it took actor finn
wolford a while to get those lines
all right then i'll use my torch i'll
use my torch too
looks like the multiple takes got the
best of caleb mclaughlin as well
i just wish i just i just wish
although with this bunch of jokers it's
really not a surprise
if there was only one shot of each scene
the show probably wouldn't look as good
as it does
but it certainly would be a barrel of
laughs i mean
how many times have you been able to
pull an axe out of a log on the first
try
thank goodness they kept all the
bloopers for us to enjoy now
when waiting on set some actors read
books
some scroll through insta but when it
comes to the cast of stranger things
their down time is a bit more elaborate
when we say the cast is musically
talented we mean it
and their range is huge from tick-tock
creations while on set to full-blown rap
songs and musical numbers on talk shows
it's never a dull moment with this crew
okay my name is 11. i'm 24 7. i mean
are they available for hire this scene
seemed to be pretty slick
a suave exit from a field of grass could
it be cuter
well the reality is it wasn't always so
graceful
while mike made a swoon he wasn't always
the knight in shining armor when 11 took
that tumble
were there any millie bobby browns
injured during the making of the show
from the looks of this probably while
violence isn't funny
the cast definitely had a lot of laughs
especially when it came to slaps
not to worry though they weren't real
although it
is impressive to see how realistic they
look
how do they even come up with this stuff
maybe there's an action film in their
futures when filming
it takes a lot of planning to get
everything just right for the perfect
shot
inevitably there are often tech and prop
malfunctions
leading to take after take after take
which can leave the actors with a whole
lot of blooper content
we're looking forward to a whole season
of bloopers
anyone else let's be real trick calling
someone has been around longer than most
of the stranger things cast members
however it seems like millie bobby brown
isn't just talented beyond her ears
but pretty skilled at a classic talent
the gag car
yeah she is is this dusty buns
she definitely gave fellow cast member
gayton matarazzo quite a scare
hey haley milly's landing in a minute
we wonder how her pa felt about those
joke calls while she was doing godzilla
boredom is bound to come about when the
actors are on set for hours on
end but obviously it was never a dull
moment for this cast and crew
who knew a boring old escalator could be
so much fun
looks like none of them could resist
this bit of adventure maybe the electric
slide should be their next musical
venture
for whatever reason the boys of stranger
things find themselves getting stuck
pretty often name something to get stuck
in and
they probably have event
check a bathroom
check stuck in this bathroom and the
door
is heavy in a chair check
we're stuck on their show so maybe
that's their secret
this may not have been on set but
considering the show is set in the 80s
it makes sense that the cast most of
whom weren't even
alive back then should learn about the
stuff that was around in that era
they definitely had some fun checking
out the goods and trying to figure out
what the stuff
was or how it was actually meant to be
used
whether or not they knew much about the
80s before filming they
definitely made the era cool again what
it's known that the cast is full of
jokers so anyone around
may be prone to getting fooled since so
many actors on set are kids
this includes parents having lots of
realistic props
definitely helps pull off a freaky trick
great for the ones pulling the stunt
not so much for noah schnapps's mom
we're glad she took the creepy joke so
well stab this tiny little
x where the smoke is yeah gayton
matarazzo
is such a lovable goofball and pulled so
many tricks
that it warranted his own pranking show
this is not a joke fans can check out
the netflix show
prank encounters for all the moderato
shenanigans
[Applause]
i know what's happening you're on my
prank show
we know what we'll be binging next we
can only
imagine how much fun it would be to hang
out on the stranger things set
the balance between spooky scripts and
lots of jokes around behind the scenes
is probably a reason why the show is so
popular
which blooper was your favorite do you
think you would have a hard time keeping
a straight face on this set
let us know what you think in the
comment section it's so cool
don't forget to like and subscribe to
keep up with us here at the things
you